homeboy our buddy uh barricade uh garage
i love this guy did his own version of
this which i think is great and let's
check it out
what could reparations look like today
whoo
politicians come on let's make it happen
did he say dead politicians i think he
just doesn't care anymore did he say
dead politician i love this man oh [ __ ]
yeah i love barricade good for him dead
politicians come on let's make it happen
mine is free chick-fil-a hot pies and
taco bell for the rest of my life
they should let black people get jordans
for free chicken
buckets of fried chicken and i just want
three million tactical assault eagles
with reinforced steel tipped razor blade
wings so we could peacefully protest at
the united nations headquarters
what could reparations look like today
um i mean money some cold hard cash
if you're any type of black you should
get paid reparations for me looks like
the prime minister of canada justin
trudeau getting kicked in the face by a
class deal wearing cleats
what can reparations look like today oh
listening when someone says my life is
being threatened
knowing that i can call the police and
actually get help and not
fear dying i want my record wipe clean
and i want
unlimited guns and ammo and someone
please
get on the phone with atn tell them
their customer service sucks and their
night vision optics
are garbage they won't even answer the
phone
[Laughter]
meant to be something like i am somebody
reparations look like [ __ ]
acknowledging the [ __ ] that happened i
just need
you to acknowledge that this has
happened no but no but
that i know we're actually watching the
parakeet garage first of course
but it's so annoying how everybody's
like but i i want to
i want the government to force you to
acknowledge my feelings basically
there's never been a promise of that in
life ever there's never been this thing
where it's like
i'm sad and everyone needs to we need to
have a whole [ __ ] day of
mourning in the city because i'm sad
it ain't that they oppress i just need
black people to understand that
believing in the black community is the
very thing keeping you a mental bondage
also it was the jewish bolshevik leon
trotsky who popularized using the term
racist against his political opponents
and as a means to emotionally manipulate
his followers
so black people until you wake up and
realize that you have been weaponized
against your own self-interest
you will always be a follower you will
always be weak
and you will always seek validation from
groups that are led by your opposition
roll my outro
he's the man i love him as soon as i
watched that last night i was like
i gotta send this away we gotta play
this dropping the red pills
he's a [ __ ] christ yeah he's a
[ __ ]
he's a beast so he came in [ __ ] hot
dude
he's gonna he's gonna he gonna learn
oh you think they're gonna get him
eventually i mean you know he's he's
doing it right now but
he's he's gonna keep pushing his [ __ ]
luck which i mean i love it
what we should try to get him on and i
would like interview him yeah i know
he's your buddy on night wave well he
did comment on one of my videos but i
haven't
spoken to him beyond that i got to find
a way to get in touch with him yeah
we'll figure it out
i'll have a man yeah i love that guy
he's so [ __ ] good man